>> Kimberly: WELCOME BACK TO
HANNITY.
DETERMINES TO SECURE A
NUCLEAR DEAL WITH IRAN, THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
DERAILED AN AMBITIOUS LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAMPAIGN
TARGETING DRUG TRAFFICKING
BY THE IRANIAN-BACKED
TERRORIST GROUP HEZBOLLAH.
EVEN AS IT WAS FUNNELING
COCAINE INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN AND RON DESANTIS ARE
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT STORY
BY SENDING A LETTER TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS.
THE CONGRESSMAN ARE ASKING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
TURN OVER ALL DOCUMENTS AND
COMMUNICATIONS RELATED TO
THIS MATTER TO FIND OUT
WHETHER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DID THIS TO
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE ON
THIS REQUEST IS CONGRESSMAN
DISTURBING AT THE SAME TIME.
CONGRESSMAN, HOW DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THE DOJ IS GOING
TO RESPOND TO YOUR REQUEST
FOR DOCUMENTS AND
INFORMATION?
>> I ACTUALLY EXPECT THEM TO
IF YOU GO BACK TO THE SECOND
TERM OF OBAMA.
REMEMBER WHAT BEN RHODES
SAID, THE IRAN DEAL IS THE
OBAMACARE OF THE SECOND
TERM.
EVERYTHING WAS SUBSERVIENT
TO THAT THEY DID ALL KINDS
OF THINGS TO GET THAT DEAL
THROUGH.
OBVIOUSLY THEY TOLD A LOT OF
FALSEHOODS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THE PROCESS.
THIS THING WITH HEZBOLLAH,
WHO BY THE WAY HAS AMERICAN
BLOOD ON ITS HANDS.
THEY ARE ONE OF THE MOST
LETHAL TERRORIST GROUPS IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
DID YOU GO ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE BEIRUT BOMBING OF THE
MARINE CORPS BARE IRAQS IN
1983, HEZBOLLAH WAS THE
PERPETRATOR OF THAT.
SO THEY HAVE BEEN REESKING
HAVOC IN THE MIDDLE EAST
AGAINST OUR ALLIES, AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES FOR
DECADES.
AND TO MAKE A CONSCIOUS
DECISION TO WARD OFF A VERY
SOPHISTICATED TASK FORCE
THAT WAS PURSUING THEM
MONEY LAUNDERING OPERATION
TO CONTINUE UNABATED AND
THEREFORE EMPOWER HEZBOLLAH,
THAT IS A VERY MONUMENTAL
AND I THINK DISASTROUS
DECISION.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO TOLD
SO ARCHITECTS OF THE IRAN
DEAL LIKE BEN RHODES AND SEE
WERE THEY INVOLVED WITH
HAVING DOJ SHUT THIS DOWN?
>> Kimberly: YOU ARE SO
RIGHT.
BEN RHODES, ALL ROADS LEAD
BACK TO HIM.
HE HAS THE ANSWERS.
HE IS THE ARCHITECT OF THAT
IT SOUNDS LIKE FROM HIS OWN
WORDS, HIS OWN ADMISSION HE
IS MAKING HIMSELF AN IDEAL
SUBJECT OF AN INVESTIGATION
TO COMPLY AND COME FORWARD
AND PROFFER SOME TESTIMONY
TO EXPLAIN EXACTLY WHAT
ABOUT CREATING A FAKE ECHO
CHAMBER.
>> Kimberly: REMEMBER?
>> WHERE HE IT JOURNALISTS
PUT OUT DISINFORMATION HOW
THEY KNEW THAT WASN'T TRUE.
THEY KNEW THE MULLAHS
WEREN'T CHANGING.
THEY THOUGHT GIVING THEM
$150 BILLION OF SANCTIONS
RELIEF AIR LIFTING OVER
$1 MILLION TO THEM IN CASH,
THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS GOOD
AND THAT WAS THE POLICY THEY
PURSUED.
I THINK THEY PURSUED IT
RECKLESSLY BUT BY THIS
INVESTIGATION WE ARE GOING
TO FIND OUT JUST HOW
RECKLESS THEY WERE IN DOING
THAT.
I QUESTION ITS MERITS.
I QUESTION IT'S YOU A
AUTHENTICITY.
WHAT DID THEY THINK THEY
WERE ACCOMPLISHING?
WAS THIS SOME TYPE OF EGO
TROPHY THINK THEY COULD DO
EGO DEAL BAD DEAL FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND NOW WE
KNOW JUST HOW BAD.
>> EXACTLY.
THEY WANTED TO HOLD UP THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" THE NEXT
DAY AND SAY OH, WE HAVE THIS
GREAT DEAL, PEACE IN OUR
TIME.
CONSEQUENCESSEN
CONSEQUENCES BN
CONSEQUENCES BE DAMNED,
ESSENTIALLY.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE DEAL.
THEY NEVER DID ANYTHING TO
PREVENT IRAN FROM DEVELOPING
BALLISTIC MISSILES.
NOTHING IN THE DEAL.
OF COURSE WE DON'T EVEN HAVE
ACCESS TO IRAN'S MILITARY
SITE IN THIS DEAL.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S CORRECT.
>> IT'S REALLY A DEAL THAT
EMPOWERED IRAN IMMEDIATELY
AND PAVED THE WAY FOR IRAN
TO DEVELOP NUCLEAR WEAPONS
IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
IT WAS A DISASTROUS DEAL.
BUT THEN YOU ALSO SEE NOW
SOME OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
HEZBOLLAH.
I THINK IF YOU ASK SOMEBODY
LIKE PRIME MINISTER
NETANYAHU OF ISRAEL.
>> Kimberly: ABSOLUTELY.
>> HE IS WORRIED ABOUT
GROUPS LIKE ISIS.
I THINK HE WOULD PROBABLY
POINT TO HEZBOLLAH AS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT TERRORIST
GROUP IN HIS NECK OF THE
WOODS.
>> Kimberly: ABSOLUTELY.
HE ALSO TRIED TO POINT THAT
OUT AT THE TIME WHEN HE WAS
STATING HIS OBJECTIONS TO
THE UNITED STATES, MAKING
THIS MOVE BECAUSE HE KNOWS
FULL WELL WHO BETTER THAN HE
TO DETERMINE AND DECIDE
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THAT REGION.
ESPECIALLY BASED ON THEIR
EXCELLENT INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING.
WE ALREADY KNOW IT.
WE KNEW THAT WAS A BAD DEAL
AT THE TIME.
BUT NEVERTHELESS IT WAS
PUSHED FORWARD AND NOW WE
ARE FINDING OUT THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF IT.
IT REMINDS ME OF THE FAST
AND FURIOUS COVERUP THERE
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT JUST SEEMS THAT THEY HAD
A SPECIFIC POLITICAL GOAL IN
UNITED STATES AND SUPPORTED
ESSENTIALLY TERRORISM WITH
IRAN AND HEZBOLLAH AND
FUNDED IT.
>> AND PROBABLY ON BOTH ENDS
BY HAVING THE DEA STAND DOWN
THAT EMPOWERED HEZBOLLAH ON
THE FRONT END.
BUT WHEN THEY'RE GETTING THE
PALACE OF CASH ON THE BACK
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GIVE
THAT TO THE REVOLUTIONARY
GUARD CORPS AND GIVE IT TO
GROUPS LIKE HEZBOLLAH SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO REEK
HAVOC IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
IT WAS A DISASTER FROM THE
FINDING OUT THE REST OF THIS
INFORMATION.